off to a good start again this year 1-0
with a 3-2-7
coming off a real good start last time
out against the yankees
six and two-thirds four strikeouts no
runs this guy contreras strikes out
about one every three at bats
and make it one for one tonight anderson
heats him up upstairs
two up two down his first strikeout and
the pitch
swing and a miss three up three down
back-to-back strikeouts anderson
continues to roll
starting pitcher for the cubs
right-hander trevor williams
the inside corner already frozen great
pitch
[Applause]
two-two swing and a miss there's the
slider he got chase
and he gets the strikeout
there's a shot to right haywards gonna
have to play that one off the fence
dansby cuts the bag at second on his way
to third
they're going to stop him as hayward
gets it into rizzo
austin reilly with a double with one out
and atlanta's in business in the second
second
and third against trevor williams gets
the second out
but now he's got to face cucuna
and no place to put ronald here comes
the 3-2 the runners will be moving there
they go
swinging a pop fly right side foul
playable for rizzo he's got it
and trevor williams gets out of the jam
braves
him loaded in the second inning could
not produce a run now they have a runner
in scoring position with two down
and we'll see if travis can give marcel
a lift home here in the bottom of the
third inning and break up this scoreless
tie
the pitch popped up shallow center
horner out
coming in marisnick makes the call and
the catch
david bode struck out his first time up
he's able to use all the quadrants of
the strike zone he changes speeds he
locates he pitches well beyond 22 years
a spicy curve ball gets bogey that's
number five
in the strikeout column two outs
into the shift dansby's right there
rizzo
will be thrown out three more up three
more down
braves bats go back to work with dansby
swanson in his scoreless game
williams back to work and he gets him to
chase
trevor williams bringing his sage here
tonight
what up one down
[Applause]
riley reaches for one swings and misses
another sharp slider by
trevor williams here comes the 02 to
heredia
check swing did he go strike three
trevor williams strikes out the side
top of the order now ronald acuna jr fly
ball felt it he's back long home run
how far up the bleachers is that going
was hammered so his first hit since
april 17th
481 feet for acuna
bernazzi the batter oh for two is he
ozzy fly ball will hit toward right
hayward turns still going back gets off
the bricks good jump by freddy look at
him streaking around
third here he comes ozzy albies doubles
off the wall and the braves get another
two-out run
[Applause]
it was just enough for him to get caught
in between and then not be able to
take the carrum the way he wanted to and
needed to to keep freddy from scoring
watch freddie run the bases this was
laurie walker like
look at how elegantly he cut the bags
ian anderson's got a two-nothing lead as
he goes to work in the sixth inning
got him swinging a miss change up
seven strikeouts for ian anderson he
comes back to get the cubs pinch hitter
and his season high strikeout total is
seven which he's matched tonight
this year
and he adds to that total back-to-back
strikeouts that's number eight
that one with a 95 mile an hour fastball
tom nothing for these guys to eliminate
anderson's on quite a roll tommy he's
got a nice scoreless streak
13 scoreless innings or thereabouts for
the brave starter 12 and two thirds by
our graphic
very few walks 12 strikeouts and tonight
he's allowed
one hit here ground ball bodhi makes
contact dansby from the cut of the
outfield grass
and there's the first out
as this one is cracked toward that
braves bullpen heredia on the run slows
down
says he's got room that ball died yeah
it did i thought rizzo got it
but he's a long loud second out
yeah he went a long way to get that ball
looked good off the bat
but like you said it just hung up a
little bit gave heredi enough time to
get to it
nice play next pitch will be his 90th
and the [ __ ] to duffy that's lifted out
towards right
coming in now ronald acuna and that's a
nice and easy seventh inning
down they go one two three that's the
fifth time they've gone
down in order versus ian and he is the
master of his domain tonight
so a seven inning start for ian anderson
who gives way to aj minter in the eighth
inning hayward mariznick
and happ are scheduled two on
and on the ground freddy freeman back
pedals he's gonna have to race to the
back and feed his buddy hayward and he
did by a quarter step and a slide that
was a foot race between minter and
hayward and freddie recognized he had to
bust it to the bag and he got there just
in time that's the trouble you have
sometimes with left-handed pitchers that
fall off the mound to the third base
side
[Music]
as this one is scorched toward left
center field mauriznick on the run still
going
it's off the base of the wall and ozzie
albies has a long
lead off double field comes in for
dansby swanson who's got a couple of
hits
in three tries as this one's lined into
right field a big insurance run has
driven home for dansby swanson
another opposite field hit and atlanta
works over workmen again
it's three to nothing so pablo sandoval
will
bat for aj menteur pitch sandoval
[Applause]
left center scores a run dansby comes
home
riley goes first to third and pablo
sandoval
helps the braves double the lead with a
two-run eighth
freddie freeman is going to come up with
the bases loaded
the shift on the pitch is a bases loaded
walk
so atlanta cashes in the horner error
third run is in in the inning
back back-to-back walks
modi awaits the o2 and it is a baker's
dozen swinging to miss
the braves one hit making two hit the
chicago cubs